I don't believe it is important in a way
that geographically we are in
economically there are some roads major
roads going through badra some other
places
what is important for us while we're
holding it so much because we have to
find time
to prepare our reserves for our counter
offensive that's where we hold down the
Russians while being been actually
working on training and supplying our
our counter offensive
being in the paper at the weekend that
your spring offensive hasn't started why
not first of all we are not signaling
Russians when we're starting and second
it's obviously this weather is not
allowing so far the heavy tanks to move
in Ukraine your usual spring mud so the
weather is playing a key part this one
of this and then we're we're not you
know telling them exact day
an exact Direction
what about the tanks that have been
provided by your European allies where
are we with that I was reading yesterday
that we received 98 of everything we
asked for this particular control fans
as you remember we had 14 British tanks
they came first breaking through this
you know
moratoriums heavy ammunition but now in
the mass the german-made leopards are
there and the Americans are coming as
well but there are a lot of different
machines are coming with the tank so
that will be the whole sort of armored
fist okay and you are still hoping
against hope that potentially you might
get fighter jets but again you're being
told no
yes you're right the biggest problem the
Russians started to bombard us from
their own territory they're not even
crossing the Ukrainian border
sending the rockets and then bombs now
over to our cities so to be able to get
these targets from the air we need
something which will be in the air like
aircrafts and we're still not receiving
them there are different explanations
and most important is that we'll have to
have time to prepare our Pilots but
that's our argument let's start
preparing Pilots
train them until you make the political
decision
I read sirens in the early hours of the
morning over many of your major cities
including the capital is this
progressively where the fight is going
to be in the air
we believe that Russians are doing it
and they're blowing us out proportions
they're reporting hundreds of rockets in
reality there were just dozens of them
sent out where most of them been being
killed and tear by our own chair I guess
they're trying to balance you know
somehow to tell Russians that we're
still in charge we're still moving which
is not obviously they can take this
teeny tiny ten thousand people city of
Bahamut
um let's talk about Mission fatigue
should we um I was looking at some
figures that suggested in the mid-1980s
wars generally lasted about on average
13 years in 2021 that's now gone up to
nearly 20 years who would have thought
that before the war started that we
would still be sitting here having this
conversation and it doesn't look as
though there's any end inside
if you remember when we had these
conversations we were discussing that it
won't be that easy for Russians as they
promised they will come into three days
they will get over the whole Ukraine so
that's where we are right now but you're
right this is getting a bit too long and
Ukraine is also suffering the eight
million of us outside of the nation so
you can imagine that most families
who are living
separated separated in a modern year so
we're losing people we have estimate
numbers of Russians being killed almost
200 thousands of them our loss is not
that big but still still very sensitive
we cherish each and every life so where
it's going that's a good question that's
why we're trying to have this you know
really breakthrough offensive
but too much hope is put on this one
okay
um when ukrainians came to the United
Kingdom they they were given um
three-year visas I believe to stay here
um not thinking for a second that they
would need that length of time
increasingly potentially they will
that's actually a very good point
because in some Nations mostly European
Union were working one year Visa so in a
way you were seeing how it would become
right now the problem is that's right it
is three years we don't believe that it
will stay here for three years but there
is the 165 thousands of ukrainians here
as a big number for us we're a big
nation but still the losses are huge the
interesting point now how many of them
will get back especially you just were
talking about kids in the exams that our
our kids also going through your exams
not Ukrainian exams so the getting
Ukrainian universities
they will have to you know to repeat the
Ukrainian exams and I doubt that all of
them will
do you still feel the support for the
Ukrainian people that there was before
the start of the war
obviously these the novelty of Ukrainian
war is fading away and support is still
here but this we're not on the front
pages of in usage in every day as we
used to be so the people because of the
many other tragedies in the world we
understand how it works the reality dark
reality of this but the support here yes
we are quite happy that we have it I'm
talking politics again if I may China
voted yes to a United Nations General
Assembly resolution for cooperation
between the UN and the Council of Europe
which included language condemning
Russian aggression
what are you reading into that
that's right that's actually the first
time they are so obvious in the support
of international law we're not talking
about only Ukraine we're talking that
China has to support the efforts
International efforts there are some
rules address our
agreements treaties Nations and that's
where Chinese sort of getting slowly
gradually to I believe that there is a
lot of been done by by Ukraine inside
president zulinsky's you know finally
talked to the president of China so we
have this sort of preach established
after the obvious support to put in
because she came to Moscow to show us
him support so I believe that he's
trying to you know to balance the
approach and find the best what is best
for China in all this the situation do
you feel that China though could
potentially broker at some sort of Peace
plan we do not like very much what China
already offered as a peace plan they're
very vague and very generalistic what we
expect them to do to do something when
they tell the respect ukrainian's event
you respect Ukrainian territorial
Integrity so we want the next step to be
done so if you respect it if you believe
that this is a core of our agreements
and our relations why wouldn't you help
us to restore this Integrity finally
Before I Let You Go how weary are the
Ukrainian people at this continuing War
they are but they're still very high the
support of presidents and armed forces
are doing the support of our forces is
enormous it's just hierarchy almost 100
percent of ukrainians are supporting
what the the girls and boys are doing at
the front lines and we're still fighting
we'll be fighting to the end